[Music]
hey guys this is Inka and today I'm
gonna be trying to make the really cool
looking tornado omelet rice some of you
may have heard about omelet rice before
it's also known as omurice in Japan
where it's an omelet served over fried
rice some of you may have also seen
Andrew fly to Japan a while back just to
learn from one of the og omurice masters
the version I'll be doing today will be
a little bit different this tornado
omelet rice actually came from one of
the street food vendors in South Korea
they kind of like twirl the egg while
it's still hot in the pan it creates
this sort of like a vortex situation and
it blew so many people away that there
were lines out the door every single
that it looks really impressive and I
think it's a really cool technique so
I'm gonna be trying to make it at home I
don't know if I have the skills for it
but I do have the tools for it and I
like to think that I use my chopsticks
pretty well so let's do some
experimenting today hopefully you will
succeed and I won't just end up with a
pile of scrambled eggs okay let's do it
so I'm gonna start with the thing that I
think I can do without a problem which
is the fried rice our base for the
omelet rice because if it doesn't have
like a little pile of rice there when
you put the egg on there it's just going
to look like a plate of eggs and the
phrase I'm gonna do is just gonna be the
typical ones that I think are served
with omurice
which is a ketchup based fried rice with
some sort of protein and veggies filling
with some bacon shallots and carrots and
of course I also have some kitchen big
bottle right here Bacon's going in first
then I'm just gonna add in the veggies
once I see some color that's what I'm
gonna add in our rice key ingredient
here that like sizzle and pop all that
goodness it is
I'll catch up to shine I'm gonna add it
right in the middle here that can help
bring out its sweetness and give that a
little fry in here then we can combine
this is my fried rice I think pretty
good now I'm just gonna scoop it back
into that bowl so I can make a perfect
mound of rice later I'm gonna squish it
down I'm grabbing a plate hand is on the
rice here and we're just going to do
this it reads in the center that's in a
pretty good shape now that I have my
fried rice done my warm-up done this is
the only part I felt really confident
about I'm gonna go into making the
actual tornado egg everything has to
happen really fast once the egg is done
trying to hype myself up worst comes to
worst I still have a really tasty plate
of fried rice to eat okay let's get to
egg making just cracking some eggs
housing - can you do one hand yes sweep
this up I'm really nervous you guys so
what I saw if I'm late by like a couple
of seconds I'm done the egg and dot the
level of responsibility is intense this
is super well combined just talk till
he's hot that's hot
saw to his smaller pan add some oil test
to see if it's ready it is totally ready
oh my god I'm gonna start cooking really
fast once I put this on there I'm I'm
nervous I'm nervous we're gonna do this
first attempt let's go all right okay
it's bubbling nice to see some bubbles
and now I'm going to you guys I think I
waited too long
no I waited too long and now it's just a
very nice scrambled egg but it is not
what I want
the first attempt is a fail I think I
just like the moment I put it in I
should have just went win with the
chopsticks and I'm gonna eat this later
put this aside for now I'm so mad at
myself
okay attempt number two and a Hanoi 'el
I'm also changing it to slightly lower
heat because like I was pretty slow I'm
really hoping that we'll be able to get
this down and not have to eat only eggs
for the next couple of days let's go
alright it looks promising
now we slowly swirl it this is not how
they did it I'm literally doing a full
360 keeping it an inch apart why is it
not moving anymore I was so close in the
beginning we did have that like
beautiful sorrel this is what I have
right now I don't think it's too bad for
a second try I think I just need to
manage the heat a little bit better I
got really excited and I think maybe I
got too excited and that's why I didn't
work anymore ah put this aside and we
move into our third attempt I'm crying
on the inside
I refuse to be defeated by these eggs I
know I can do it it's so close I have to
make this work third try let's go please
let this be the last try
there are time's the charm right I'm
gonna do this thing that they did
separate the two chopstick
other like that
[Music]
your guys think it right
it did it took it out slowly take it out
slowly take it out slowly oh okay okay
okay okay while it's still hot I'm gonna
transfer it to the fried rice oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god I cannot
mess up here
[Music]
oh don't worry that eggs gonna keep
cooking I am so happy I'm so I yes oh my
god like this close to running out of
eggs we did it
is it perfect no I don't think so
but is it close to what I saw in the
videos yes I'm going to add in the
demi-glace sauce and maids just to
finish this up but I am you guys I am
honestly so happy I'm sorry
this looks so bad can't believe the guy
here
[Music]
Eli's it is done it smells so good the
exit well well I cannot wait to eat this
you guys can see these folds oh my
goodness
and it goes all the way around it's
almost like a little egg blanket toga
wrap I love how this looks it's such a
pretty way to serve up omurice I'm a
little sad that I have to break this
beautiful fold but whoa all that hard
work I put in this egg not only does it
look incredible but it tastes amazing
because it has not like perfect velvety
smooth texture and you get those like
thin folds and wow I'm just Wow no
wonder people line up for this it
definitely took a few tries but I think
this is one of those challenges that are
worth attempting at home let me know if
you give this a try - I'm really looking
forward to your pictures and videos
anyways I will see you guys next time
bye
[Music]